après j'espère que c'est pas su soleil
parce que nous savons parfait est-ce que
moi une baisse ils sont allés est-ce
qu'elle est à bamako
non à la technique insu et au sénégal
est atteint
[Musique]
alors sur ses superbes images du canada
qui pour certains d'entre elles datent
de l'été qui fit en cours bienvenue à
tam tam canada à votre émission qui vous
parlait en direct de montréal avec
l'équipe française en pas su souvent des
équipes de d'autres sections également
se joignent à nous cette semaine on vous
fait grâce du thème de l'émission
puisque apparemment l'informatique
quelques passes en est saisi et il a
envoyé quelque part tous ces gens mus
l'informatique c'est toujours le grand
vilain dans nos affaires alors premier
la semaine prochaine on va retrouver le
thème d'autant canada le retrouver même
afin d'initier une bonne saison retrouve
le thème il faudrait le faire nous
entendu un peu de ce thème et après tu
aimes ce soir c'est le préfet qui
annonce le thème normalement c'est
toujours un prétexte dans vos affaires
écoutez moi je vous retrouve également
après trois semaines de vacances
je veux faire le tour rapidement parce
que moi je suis tout à fait reposer un
peu plus foncé chez comme vous
jeunechamp amérindiens alors j'en
profite
le csii a pas beaucoup de soleil mais il
ya eu deux jours de cela ils voient les
résultats
alors écoutez vous prenez des vacances
cet été oui je vais au portugal bravo la
bernard l'année dernière c'était où les
casses l'ecosse et portugaise cinq ans
pas vraiment ça quand ça s'est passé
sinon non travaille toujours au moins
ben beaucoup de rédactions
un roman qui s'en vient
deuxième roman de raymond 3e 3e 11e ont
le temps file à la deuxième va sortir en
octobre
et le troisième est en phase finale de
vide devrait faire une émission spéciale
juste des coups lui les challenges vous
prenez des vacances un tout petit peu
week-end que deux semaines pour rester à
mon rien dans le chaudron ses choix
montréal l'été à kaya pas de moi c'est
chaud là où c'est sûr que c'est très
très sain avec tout le bitume et puis le
les armes qu'on enlève écouter
aujourd'hui vous connaissez comme à ça
fonctionne vous n'avez aucune idée du
sujet des missions je confirme avec
comme erik lund
oui avec l'oncf ouest en chef mais vous
savez elle lit pas les mémos donc alors
pour savoir quel est le sujet tout le
monde peut jouer à la maison au bureau
ou dans l'avion voici la vidéo 5 images
vous crier dès que vous pensez être sur
la piste on regarde son ensemble il ya
ces images en fait la sixième donne
réponse oui l'élevage plus ça animaux
oui tout à fait oui donc on est dans le
monde de l'élevage mai encore oui en
partie mais pas vraiment à a pas l'air
très bien lui un la maltraitance
oui la maltraitance à côté et le
mieux-être des années de baisse
pis y ait des avancées dans ce domaine
ça fait des années on dit les animaux ne
sont pas protégés parce que mon canada
c'est pas ça se passe mieux en europe de
ce côté-là nous un petit peu de recul un
petit peu de retard mais depuis quelques
temps il ya eu des avancées mois depuis
six ans que je traite les dossiers
radio-canada internationalement sur
cette question là je suis aperçu de
certaines avancées mais pas seulement
bon c'est pas tout à fait réglé comme à
faire alors on va essayer de voir où se
place le canada par rapport aux états
unis à la france si tu es ce dossier là
les animaux sans défense
et puis c'est anormal que l'on s'en
occupe pas compris que pas
des animaux le ferai c'est mon
commentaire éditorial
vous êtes prêt pour le jour le jour de
ce musée oui on est la preuve c'est par
ici
d'accord alors ça c'est notre premier
tour de boules y en a trois à chaque
émission vous avez sambou la perte
durant l'émission
vous ne perdez pas tout à chaque que je
vous risquez de perdre un certain nombre
pour ce premier jeu c'est 20 boules à
perdre d'accord voici on affiche à
l'écran alors aussi on affiche est-ce
qu'on peut afficher je pose la question
aux grands manitous voilà alors c'est la
première question des poulets canadiens
produisent un pourcentage combien de
fois de plus de viande que les poulets
des années 1950 1960 s à 50% d'avant de
réponse est ce que ces bébés 100% deux
fois plus
est ce que c'est c'est deux fois plus
que 3 contre 4 x 4 fois plus ou aucune
de ces réponses voilà moi j'irai au quai
de la série france aucune de ces
réponses parce que je pense qu'encore
beaucoup plus que ça ok d'accord que je
prends donc aucune de ces réponses
moi j'irai avec la fcc se serait aucune
de ce serait deux sens
ça veut dire quoi ça quatre fois plus de
viande qu'elle s'appelait zaccar quatre
fois plus de viande
je prends note si je m'en tiens au port
à la quantité de contrats sur le marché
155 seulement deux fois est bien la
bonne réponse et vous perdez tous vos
boules ont 50 cd aucune de ces raisons
j'ai dit vous perdez les boules le
guardian on se plaint beaucoup plus que
5 3 fois plus on va falloir plus besoin
donc 105 155 5 % à 200 % des sujets
aussi graves
cette chanson c'est l'habitat est
unanime avec elle
staline on sache de jouer on passe aux
choses sérieuses une vidéo je pense
c'est en 2014 est un organisme au canada
qui s'appelle maurice
c'est pas la première vidéo qu'il
publiait mise à l'aise dans les allées
faire les abattoirs surtout voilà et
puis il voyait comment on est en traiter
les animaux et une série de vidéos comme
ça ça se passe c'est un des premiers mis
en émoi les canadiens nous a réveillés
vraiment alors on regarde ça ça se passe
dans unanime pendant une animal dans une
ferme qui je pense c'est encore
britannique
un enquêteur qui a travaillé de façon
incognito avec sa mecque caméra cachée
pendant plusieurs semaines il n'avait
aucune idée de ce qu'ils allaient
trouver c'est pas encore britannique
pendant 7 à pont rouge au québec au
québec où tu as far web tout à fait vous
connaissez bien
[Rires]
on va regarder ce qu'on peut regarder et
dès que vous sentez que ce n'est plus
possible
on arrête ça on regarde quelques images
on va regarder à quoi ça sert de la
cruauté au canada donc on vous a prévenu
ça peut être mal aisé gré du récit voilà
ça commence bien
on regardera pas tout parce que c'est
assez lancer la vidéo intégrale de voilà
alors c'est ya un homme qui frappe les
bêtes et bovins c'est pas des poulets
qu'un des problèmes ensemble notre
argent
regardez ça bon écoutez je pense qu'on a
une idée quand même on n'est pas besoin
d'eux parce qu'il ya une plainte ces
derniers temps québec ouais on va
examiner cela avec notre spécialiste
à l'instant si vous voulez savoir
exactement ce qu'on avait nous et on a
une idée générale
voilà on y est à quoi ça ressemble ça
c'est en 2014
donc les choses ont évolué dit en
instant espère-t-on alors notre entrevue
aujourd'hui à sur skype peut avoir lieu
en direct avec quelqu'un qui se trouve à
dakar au sénégal
vous connaissez dakar oui bien sûr il
vous avez visité dakar oui j'étais à
dakar j'étais également un sans lui st
louis sénégal c'est à quelques
kilomètres de dakar une vive que j'ai
beaucoup aimé c'est vraiment au bord de
l'océan atlantique on à la plage
vraiment c'est très beau j'ai des
frissons en résulte que je connais
d'accord je suis passé de souvent à quai
et un bambin mais pas et qu'on verra
j'ai pas déplu à dakar j'ai vu qu'à 5 ou
6 les gars moi je te dis que vous
connaissez l'hôtel mermoz non je trouve
je ne dois mais son sourire ses deux
grands ponts 2 à la plage mais
merveilleux et puis les quartiers à
africain je te verrai ce réaliste au
niveau des couleurs mais ouais je veux
me souvenir si la couleur les couleurs
bien que ça y est le transport en commun
si oui c'est un pari osé
je laisse infuser un taxi parce que
j'étais riche mais parce que mon père y
tenait sinon c'est un vélo sur les avec
mon père qui me ma thèse sur la fourche
du vélo mais aussi écouter on va aller
voir
elsa vasseur professeur en bien-être
animal au département des sciences
animales diversité mais guère
aujourd'hui à dakar au sénégal
bonjour madame vasseur écouter et merci
d'avoir accepté notre invitation
question qui peut être personnel mais
sans doute espère-t-on professionnel
qu'est ce qui vous amène à d'accord
justement financé par le gouvernement du
québec en partenariat avec la fao au
travail et à la résilience des
changements climatiques est caractérisé
la filière lait et lapierre viande ici
avec les partenaires sénégalais voir où
est ce qu'on s'en va finalement pour
produire du lait de manière durable au
sénégal ni quand on parle de produire
les choses de manière durable c'est
aussi qu'il ya des questions éthiques
qui sont reliés à sa et la question de
la cruauté envers des animaux
on vous a consulté dans le passé vous
faites partie de la solution en même
pouvez vous nous décrire un poids vous
vous êtes impliqué dans cette question
là oui bien sûr alors oui je suis
professeur mais celui-ci titulaire d'une
chaire de recherche industrielle qui est
financé par le crs ndjeng don qui est un
organisme public de recherche et des
rares et l'industrie l'industrie
laitière donc les producteurs et des
transformateurs de lait du québec et du
canada
les travaux de la chose c'est finalement
essayé de trouver des moyens pour
améliorer la condition de vie des
animaux et comment garder les animaux
plus longtemps dans un troupeau
et oui le focus c'est vraiment sur la
production laitière
alors on va montrer je pense que vous
avez même le voir vous même des images
tournées par 6 bis si radio-canada assez
récemment au sujet de la production des
poulets là il ya des poulets qui sont
encore bien à d'autres qui sont vivants
qui bat de l aile on les frappe
voyez comment on les traite alors qu'ils
sont en cage alors bon ça c'est des
images tournées par cbi ci comment ça se
passe aujourd'hui en réalité est-ce que
c'est toujours ça on voit où
là on exagère céder la force nouvelle
finale c'est un peu exagéré parce que
vous êtes en train de montrer c'est dans
un abattoir où c'est en l'occurrence
peut être dans un endroit où on accuse m
je vais vous parler de ce qui se passe
donc les productions animales au canada
sont soumises à des réductions de code
de pratique
1 les codes de pratiques bien sûr qu'est
ce que c'est on met tous les acteurs
autour de la table
d'abord c'est géré par le conseil
national les bons soins des animaux
on a cité sur un acteur on a assez des
chercheurs ont assez des transformateurs
en assez des produits pains et on décide
finalement qu'est-ce qu'on connaît qu'on
est un scientifique des bonnes pratiques
d'élevage est ce qu'on est capable de
faire mieux et décider finalement quels
seront les standards en production pour
les différentes productions ya donc là
en ce moment moi je suis impliqué dans
la révision du code de pratique pour lui
les évadés d'un processus qui fait tous
les dix ans alors les codes de pratiques
il ya plusieurs utilisations par exemple
en colombie britannique
récemment ils ont adopté le code de
pratique dans l'eure dans leur voyons
dans leur système législatif provincial
pour décider finalement qu'est ce qui
est acceptable et qu'est ce qui n'est
acceptable en termes de pratiques puis
par exemple les producteurs de lait mais
l'ensemble des producteurs ça se met en
place aujourd'hui des systèmes de
certification pour s'assurer que ce qui
est dans le code de pratique c'est
vraiment ce qu'on va cibler avoir dans
les airs
vous avez des questions oui j'aurais une
question c'est madame elsa vassard
depuis que vous êtes au sénégal est ce
que vous avez eu le temps de descendre
sur le terrain pour aller évaluer les
pratiques de ces populations lancer qui
a trait aux droits des animaux et en ce
qui a trait aussi à la gestion durable
de la production laitière
alors c'est une bonne question alors
malheureusement moi j'ai pas le temps
d'aller sur le terrain c'est pour ça que
j'ai des étudiants qui sont locaux ont
d'ailleurs qui je parle avec des
universités locales
on forme des jeunes
ils vont faire les enquêtes et bon allez
rencontrer les éleveurs
donc je on est vraiment au début du
projet le projet vient tout juste d'être
lancé
donc j'ai pas encore de donner ce que je
pouvais vous dire c'est que ici on
trouve différents systèmes on trouve les
passeports dont des gens qui sont
nomades et qui on a un élevage très très
extensif puis on a des fermes beaucoup
plus intensive comme on les retrouve
finalement au canada avec des races
laitières et on a toute une série mx de
gens qui produisent du lait ont pour
appeler les systèmes semi intensif
d'ailleurs si c'est là dessus qu'on va
trancher et tu donc non j'ai pas plus
d'information ça mais je peux vous dire
que probablement les problèmes on trouve
au canada on pourrait aussi les trouver
ici et il ya beaucoup de questions sur
est-ce qu'on a une bonne gestion est ce
qu'on a un bon encadrement et surtout
est-ce qu'on a des bonnes connaissances
assure recevoir dans votre titre
officiel il ya bien être animal
est ce assez c'est même très
philosophique par rapport à l' approche
la tension quitte le terrain puis on
s'en va vers la notion même j'imagine
qu'il ya autant de définitions qui a
deux systèmes d'opération et systèmes de
production donc le bien-être animal
c'est une science un qui à 50 ans qu'on
ne sait pas si vieux et comme vous
l'avez indiqué ont passé c'est un
système aurait regardé trois choses on
va regarder la manière dont fonctionnent
les animaux biologiquement est-ce qu'on
a des aliments santé
on va regarder si on leur fournit un
environnement dans lequel ils sont
capables d'avoir des comportements
naturels on appelle naturelles et la
troisième pension c'est effectivement le
côté des émotions du ressenti alors
aujourd'hui on a des très bons
indicateurs notamment sur vous les
sentez on a une bonne idée de caisse que
l'on doit retrouver quels sont les
comptes sont plus naturels et on
travaille très fort en fait sur le volet
des émotions d'ailleurs mon travail sur
cet ensemble sur ces différents
indicateurs dans le cadre de mes travaux
de recherche
par exemple si on veut augmenter les
opportunités de mouvement commencé en ce
moment en production laitière ont fait
des études
regardez finalement qu'est-ce que ça
veut dire donner plus de mouvement
qu'est ce que ça veut dire sortir des
animaux dehors on regarde aussi le volet
motivation regarde le volet frustration
qui on regarde aussi l'amélioration par
exemple de la locomotion vous entendre
vous parlais tout à l'heure d'une
certification pour les éleveurs pour les
vaches laitières
les producteurs de lait pouvez vous nous
donner comme sommairement description
des mesures qui doivent prendre pour
obtenir cette certification là où bien
sûr voyez il ya eu donc ça c'est quelque
chose qui a quand même démarré il ya
quelques années aujourd'hui la
certification et on court à tous les
éleveurs au canada sont en train d'avoir
leur première audit pour voir où est ce
qu'ils sont et ce qu'ils en sont pour
évaluer le niveau et puis de de prendre
des mesures pour pouvoir s'améliorer ça
s'est fait dans chacun des élevages ce
qui a été fait comme choix c'est de
prendre des mesures de résultats c'est à
dire que qu'importe les pratiques
d'élevage et l'environnement si vous
donnez ce qu'il faut pour que les
animaux et on devrait être capable de le
mesurer et c'est ce qu'on fait on mesure
par exemple le niveau de blessure mesure
les boiteries on mesure donc la manière
dont les animaux se déplace on mesure
les états de chair donc avec l'idée de
dire on ne veut pas arriver avec un m a
mesuré dire çà doit être tel espace mais
plutôt de se dire il ya des contraintes
budgétaires il ya des gars des
ressources
il ya des fermes qui sont plus vieille
en a qui sont neuf mais il ya des
pratiques qui permettent de compenser
pour finalement garder des animaux dans
les meilleures conditions qu'au canada
on mesure les résultats
oui en fait si j'ai bien suivi le sens
de vos précédentes explications votre
démarche suit le terrain au sénégal
consistera aussi à renforcer les
capacités opérationnelles des élevages
sur le terrain et dites moi comment ça
va se faire concrètement est ce que vous
avez comme des groupes d'étudiants qui
vont descendre sur le terrain à la
rencontre de ces 2 16 et 2
ou vous attardez les mobiliser autour de
vous je sais pas comment ça va se passer
alors vous voyez le mandat qu'on s'est
donné avec les différents gouvernements
forcément le gouvernement du sénégal est
impliquée dans des projets qu'on sait
des projets de collaboration avec la fao
le mandat qu'on s'est donné non c'est de
faire une caractérisation en fait que
des différents niveaux densification et
puis de regarder c'est quoi la
durabilité des systèmes en regardant des
indicateurs économiques culturels
sociaux et bien sûr aussi environnement
donc on va regarder l'ensemble parce que
par exemple
voyez les élevages quand ils sont la
place de la femme est très important ici
au sénégal on commence à voir des
élevages qui sont pros
finalement c'est plutôt des mesures qui
vont qui vont avoir les clés des taaf
vous voyez il ya une série de choses et
notre travail à nous c'est de bien
caractériser l'ensemble de l'échelle
finalement dans la consultation pour
quelque part donné au sénégal les des
nouvelles connaissances sur qu'est ce
que ça veut dire
l'intensification et prendre les
finalement des décisions sur est ce que
il faut qu'on développe méfie des relais
au sénégal où est-ce qu'il faut qu'on
continue à utiliser la poudre de lait
importée est subventionné par la
communauté européenne
aujourd'hui les produits laitiers sont
basés sur la professeure vasseur on a
des choses à apprendre de tous les
autres bien sûr comme le sénégal a des
choses à apprendre
grâce à notre expertise qu'est ce qu'on
a à prendre des européens sur le
traitement des animaux de ferme
il ya de la législation là bas il ya des
chaussées des avancées qui n'existe pas
encore ici semble-t-il où ça en europe
c'est ça que vous dites oui elle aurait
coûté en europe le système qu'ils ont
choisi ces travailler sur de la
réglementation le problème de la
réglementation c'est c'est bien d'avoir
une réglementation mais comment s'assure
que sur le terrain finalement les choses
qui ont été décidées sont vraiment mises
en place
je pense qu'il faut mieux
c'est bien il ya des directives
européennes qui sont votées ça ça ça
montre qu'on veut s'améliorer
moi je vous dirai ce que j'aime beaucoup
du système ici au canada c'est
finalement d'asseoir que les acteurs au
tout la table et décider
qu'est ce qu'on veut faire demain
aujourd'hui même des produits pour l'été
sont en train de mettre leurs systèmes
de certification restants sont en train
de s'améliorer
c'est à dire qu'ils n'attendent pas que
le gouvernement du canada va aller payer
des inspections pour regarder sur mes
profondes améliorer des choses
donc voyez oui c'est vrai ça fait bien
plus montré au canada un qui a des
discussions des décisions qui ont été
prises en europe et je pense qu'on a un
système quand même assez efficace ici au
canada et finalement créé transparent
c'est quand même très rare on se fait on
se faire inviter souvent à venir
présenter sur comment marche le système
parce que finalement c'est très très
rare d'avoir à la table l'ensemble des
acteurs et de prendre des décisions
basées sur une revue de littérature puis
nous on prévoit deux ans de prise de
décision parce que c'est sur ces longues
d'avoir un consensus pour décider mais
finalement qu'est ce qui est acceptable
ou est ce qu on veut s'améliorer à skis
à des pratiques améliorées en production
laitière par exemple et qu'est-ce qu'on
veut demain qui sera obligatoire dans
chacune des vernis sont pourtant des
fermes du canada ça prend un petit peu
de temps quand on a autant d'acteurs
autour de la table mais ça marche
vraiment ben c'est juste une boutade
c'est que j'aime beaucoup savoir que
vous êtes dakar au sénégal et qui est en
voie de réponse vous avez dit deux fois
ici au canada et partout où il se sent
bien partout elle est mandatée par le
canada je voulais moi quand je faisais
la recherche sur cette question là il ya
quand même plusieurs semaines je me suis
arrêté commencé à m'intéresser à ça j'ai
vu qu'aux états unis au niveau par
exemple des poulets on gardait les
poulets propre en utilisant du chlore
puis en asie c'étaient d'autres
techniques qu'on utilisait qui était pas
décemment à bonn non plus en
ça causait des brûlures etc se terrait
chez les rats qu'est ce que le canada
prenons l'exemple précis des poulets
parce que c'est la langue la langue la
viande préférée des canadiens de loin
qu'est ce qui se fait au niveau de
l'élevage des poulets qui ne se fait
plus par rapport à ce qui se faisait il
ya dix ans montrez-nous un progrès
quelque chose je pensais que vous allez
me parler des pondeuses parce que ça
d'être un petit peu facile vont pouvoir
que je sais pas malheureusement je suis
pas spécialiste de tous les élevages
qu'est ce qui se fait qu'est-ce qu'il
fait pas quelque chose en tout cas qui
va arrêter d'être fait c'est
l'utilisation des antibiotiques de
manière préventive
st il ya en europe on a décidé que s'est
arrêté on sait que ça fonctionne
alain vous voyez ça va changer beaucoup
les pratiques parce qu'à partir du
moment où on décide de plus donnée
d'antibiotiques et on continue ça veut
dire qu'il va falloir avoir des
pratiques qui permettent de prévenir en
fait il ya beaucoup de chances qu'ils
vont changer et je pense qu'on on est
vraiment dans une phase intéressante
voyez les antibiotiques à la base de
permettre que les animaux restent en
santé
quand même une question importante c'est
une question bien un art là on est rendu
de dire qu'on veut arrêter de donner des
antibiotiques en prévention sur des
images aussi court que son époux l'est
parce qu'il reste quelques semaines
finalement dans des élevages
ça va demander finalement beaucoup de
travail et de repenser et finalement
comment est ce qu'on fait des choses
donc je me permettrai pas d'en parler
beaucoup plus parce que je m'intéresse
beaucoup plus au système en fait avec
des cages la stabulation entravée à des
veaux de lait les perrons c'est une
problématique vraiment sur la
restriction de mouvement donc c'est pas
mal ce sur quoi je travaille aujourd'hui
mais à jeudi la question des
antibiotiques et la nourriture c'est
quelque chose qui va changer une deux
sites web une dernière question ici
autour de la table en fait c'est sûr
qu'elle n'est pas feinte sa spécialité
où sa spécialisation ne s'étant pas ce
domaine là j'allais également parlé de
l'incidence de l'utilisation des
antibiotiques en élevage sur la santé
humaine est ce que c'est quelque chose
que vous avez eue
explorez a de toute manière des raisons
pour laquelle on veut arrêter de donner
des antibiotiques en prévention c'est
parce qu'on s'est rendu compte que il y
avait beaucoup que la population humaine
devenir résistance aux antibiotiques
dont fallait bien que ça vienne quelque
part cette résistance est à partir du
moment où ça devient une question santé
humaine je dois dire qu'on bouge très
très vite
donc ça c'est encore pour mes collègues
vétérinaire qui travaillent sur le sujet
peut-être qu'ils trouvent qu'on a pour
objet ou qu'on bouge pas assez vite
je pense que l'amélioration se fait
vraiment pas une prise de position ne
seront qu ont des problèmes par exemple
je vais vous dire pourquoi est ce que
les producteurs de lait ont décidé de
financer sur la question du bien-être un
bien sûr s'intéresse à la condition de
vie de leurs animaux mais surtout ou en
premier lieu ils se sont dit finalement
comment ça se fait qu'on a du mal à
garder les animaux souffrent dans les
élevages
est ce que finalement on est capable
d'améliorer les conditions de vie est ce
que ça va nous permettre
mais on a une bonne génétique on sait
comment nourrir non les animaux à ce
qu'on peut faire au cours mieux je pense
qu'on est un module 1 et ça c'est
quelque chose qui se fait finalement
aussi en questionnement avec les
questionnements sociétal au québec sa
part a pris quand même pas mal d'années
pour qu'on se retrouve avec une loin qui
permet de changer le statut finalement
des animaux à au lieu de passer un bien
se rendre compte que finalement c'est un
être vivant pour lequel on a des devoirs
et on se doit finalement d'améliorer les
choses
je pense que je pense que ça comme je
vous disais ça fait 50 ans
finalement seulement qu'il ya vraiment
un questionnement inquiets de la
recherche qui se fait et je pense que ça
va très très vite avec marie-claude vous
avez une dernière dernière c'est une
question c'est par rapport à la vidéo
justement sur les veaux de lait en
captivité vous dites que vous êtes votre
spécialité c'est un peu les cages
pouvez vous nous dire depuis 2000 14
depuis que ces images ont été tournées
qu'est-ce qui a été amélioré dans leur
condition ou qu'est-ce qui va l'être
eh bien écoutez c'est pareil les codes
de pratiques pour le veau comme pour les
pondeuses en fait ont été revus donc par
exemple si je prends les poupons 2
les aujourd'hui les dans le code de
pratique on ne recommande qu les
batteries en condition va parler de
cages enrichi on va parler de système
sans cage
vous voyez il ya quand même pas mal de
choses qui se fait pour essayer donc
c'est sur le principe de la cage et d'un
animal restreint dans son mouvement
c'est quelque chose qui qui avait quand
même une sensibilité pour le public est
en fait aujourd'hui on se dit comment
est ce qu'on est capable de faire
autrement et bien sûr on est capable de
faire autrement mais il faut accompagner
les producteurs et proposer des
recommandations qui vont fonctionner ça
a l'air de rien mais amener les vaches
d'hérens à des animaux qui sont jamais
allés devant et puis repenser la manière
dont on le fait nous on a pris un an
avec la firme de recherche ici pour
décider bon finalement c'est quoi la
bonne procédure pour qu'on puisse le
faire et que tout le monde se sente à
l'aise dans ce processus fin pour que
demain emplisseurs des recommandations
finalement à l'ensemble des produits
voyez c'est des choses qui on est tous
habitués à des routines à partir du
monde on va là on sort de cette routine
main ça prend vraiment des références
pour s'assurer que les producteurs sont
en train de rentrer dans le mur parce
qu'il y avait des problèmes qui vont
arriver avec des changements professeur
alain vasseur merci beaucoup
nous avons rapporté vous votre
expérience jusqu'à maintenant et puis on
le voit une expérience qui est basée sur
les expériences de terrain mais c'est
magnifique ce fantastique merci beaucoup
ce vieux en wolof est ce que c'est ça
c'est ça ouais le wolof d'accord ils
parlent la langue de tous les pays et
pauline s'est amusé à apprendre à dire
merci dans plusieurs noms pouvaient tout
autrement dit bonjour dit même pas qu'il
y ait donc qu'elles savent açores
professeur en bien-être animal au
département des sciences animales
l'université mcgill ont pas vous parler
de la bonne question la dernière des
dernières questions c'était d'avoir sur
les antibiotiques et il y avait non vous
avez vous avez aussi parlé des
antibiotiques non non non non autrefois
l'important c'est qu'on en ait pas oui
ça m'a fait penser à votre sujet cette
fin de semaine qui sera sur le web
est-ce qu'on est dangereux de manger le
poisson qu'on pêche dans le fleuve
saint-laurent et j'ai entendu parler
d'un rapport où on disait qu'il y avait
beaucoup de résidus d'antibiotiques dans
l'eau à du fleuve saint-laurent ce
moment qu'est ce qu'un lit est ce que
vous avez à nous dire sur ce sujet ce
que je peux vous dire c'est que il ya
des contaminants qui se loge dans la
chair du poisson mais des contaminants
qui se loge dans le gras du poisson les
poissons général sont des bêtes qui sont
pas grosses du tout alors le mercure wii
se loge dans la chair du poisson c'est
pour ça que dans le guide de
consommation qui est publié par le
ministère de l'environnement on parle de
mesures de mercure et on parle de
fréquence de manger le poisson par
rapport au teneur en mercure
par contre tout ce qui est contaminants
organiques d'après les spécialistes que
j'ai consultés que s'appelle monsieur
denis la liberté tout ce qui est
contaminants organiques c'est vraiment
attiré par le gr alors sa posologie qu
il ya pas de gras dans la chair moins
d'un pour cent de gros dans la chair
alors il s'agit dans la cavité
abdominale ou dans les organes donc
évidemment il recommande de ne pas
manger c'est parti là qui sont de toute
façon pas comestible enlever la peau de
faire défiler mais voilà puis troisième
conseil il faut pas manger de cachalot
de baleines parce que bon gré sont
normalement avec moi je parlais de la
faune dans le saint-laurent à la hauteur
de montréal
à l'origine les contaminants comme le
mercure le mercure 90% atmospheric
science atmosphérique danser les pluies
acides qui font tomber le mercure dans
les eaux et aux tendances et les rangs
que que dans les lacs dans le nord les
poissons sont autant ciblés par le
mercure dans les bourrasques translucide
da2 heure de montréal dans le nord que
ce sont bien souvent hélas ils sont
exposés plus longtemps parce qu'il vit
beaucoup plus longtemps dans l'art donc
ils vont avoir accumulé plus de mercure
alors chers alors
oui vous pouvez marcher votre poids tant
que puissance cette semaine vous des
riverains il suffit de bien le nettoyer
par exemple oui faut bien s'en passer on
est place au jeu maintenant on est prêts
on a combien de boules à perdre pour le
deuxième je roule 30 très bien et après
donc vous avez tous ces endroits roule
évoluer vous en reste 80
voilà ça ne porte pas sur le poisson qui
pas vraiment nécessairement la viande la
plus populaire au canada
pas vraiment pendant ma famille en tout
cas sauf enrobé pas mal de j'ai été vue
un poisson on n'en suis plus capable
c'est le capitaine et du maquereau or
c'est plus rentable à couternon way
accroc avec les oméga 3 et tous ces bons
c'est très bien des matins où j'ai un
jeu posé entendu parler de ça cette
semaine ils ont un pêcheur c'est de la
grosseur d'un requin encombré années que
ça se passe toujours à cold mountain
alors deuxième jeu voici la question on
affiche la question de la grosse boule
sur les 30 milliards d'animaux
terrestres vivent dans nos fermes
d'élevage dans le monde combien dont les
garçons des poulets parce que non
seulement c'est populaire au canada le
poulet mais aussi dans le monde canada
c'est la première viande en popularité
pas seulement par tous comme ça mais
globalement c'est une viande très
populaire alors combien sur les 30
milliards d'animaux des tresses sont des
poulets 23 milliards ca ou ce que cb la
bonne réponse 18 milliards de poulet ou
est ce que c'est c'est 13 milliards de
poulet je vais dire à 1,23 milliard ou 1
30 milliard de nombreux crs très 23
milliards de poulet c'est un peu trop ça
me semble exagéré
[Rires]
la modération les bébés alors b et puis
marie-claude vous tenez toujours à vous
mr des as
j'ai pas le droit de reculer c'est mauro
j'avais faisait la plus attentive
d'accord vous avez failli l'influencé
petite baie c'est fantastique chantal et
vous raymond robbe la dépense c'est
vraiment a toujours répondu regarde
froidement india si la question est
truqué je veux le savoir je vais voir
tout de suite parce que c est ce que les
trucs et la question 23 millions 23
milliard voilà la wii c'est à l'abri du
tiers c'est oui monsieur s'est passé
extrêmement populaire en nazi oui et à
beaucoup de gens puis en afrique après
le poisson c'est le poulet rouler oui
parce que ça kampala animaux d'élevage
et les boeufs les gros boeuf la cdc de
la viande pour les riches sans les pays
riches c'est qu'un sagaspe il a beaucoup
de ressources
veuf on va faire un reportage où notre
ville une émission spéciale là dessus on
est tout seul ça va venir
alors écoutez la régie la régie avec un
grand r on travaille à radio canada
après tout va nous amener voir la page
web de tam-tam cette semaine c'est je
sais pas ce qu'ils avaient été prévenus
mais ils vont le faire
ils ont un hyperlien qui devrait l'y
conduire voilà donc vous voyez la belle
image plusieurs d'entre vous qui
travaille à radio canada international
s'est pas actualisés comme la voilà on
va descendre on va descendre on va
descendre
non c'est pas la page web de tam-tam ça
ça c'est la page donc je me suis trompé
de pages pourraient m'écouter
j'ai une page secrète de temps donc de
tam-tam qui n'est pas disponible pour le
spanish bon c'est la semaine des farces
et attrapes mais essentiellement sur
cette page secrète qui ne sera plus dans
20 minutes parce que l'on va diffuser
notre émission l'affiché en rediffusion
verrait cinq six reportages dont
plusieurs de vous sur la question de la
cruauté des ennemis
notez animal ouvrait alors j'en ai
beaucoup parlé d'abord dernier sanary j
parce que je les élève en piètre figure
c'est pas de l'info c'est pas celle là
ouais voilà il ya le thème démission il
ya ça mais revient de vacances c'est ça
il ya trois ans j'ai peut-être que ce
que vous connaissez tous les sujets
ouzou où tu joues tu vois ça faisait des
spéciales d'informations je vous
présente cette vidéo là on peut la
présenter avec un peu de son peut-être
que certains d'entre vous les
reconnaître cette histoire ça se passe
en ontario une histoire de cochon qui
avaient soif apparemment et il ya une
personne qui travaille pour un groupe
environnemental qui décèdent intervenir
c'est un kiff nc images les pauvres
cochon à 30 degrés sur ces jeux plus
celsius
elle décide de les abreuver le
camionneur qui les a menés à l'abattoir
la filme aussi il est en colère parce
qu'il dit qu'elle intervient dans le
processus de commencer l'examen qu'il va
faire peur aux animaux
il valait compte elle va contaminer les
animaux et son no alors les deux ce film
la faire se retrouve un cours il y a
deux ans
alors tous ces animaux vous voyez sont
maintenant morts sont passés dans
l'estomac des bars et canadien une heure
plus tard ils se sont retrouvés à la ba3
s'est donc retrouvé en cours et on en a
parlé le couple de fois dans notre
formation est comme ça se fait toujours
les grands médias on oublie de dire la
suite exactement disait qu'elle était
poursuivie parce qu'elle vous a voulu
abreuver les cochons et après ça pas de
nouvelles merci pour moi aussi je veux
avoir la réponse elle a été acquitté
parce que le juge a décidé que oui elle
faisait de générer de l'intérêt au
niveau de l'environnement ces choses-là
inactive et c'est après tout ammann n'a
pas gêné le transport des animaux il est
le camionneur été arrêtée et elle n'a
pas infecté les animaux y ait pas de
danger l'arrivée rien dans l'eau qu'elle
donnait aux animaux qui fait et n'a pas
ça n'a pas causé de problème à
l'abattoir parce que les animaux avaient
pu un petit peu plus doux qui leur est
dû alors de juger a quitté la sphère et
puis voilà cette image a fait le tour de
cette vidéo a fait le tour du monde et
c'est aussi c'est le commentaire du
camionneur comment il l'a appelée qui
était pouvoir parce qu'il a dit non
c'est un juron anglais à la française
c'est ce que ce n'était pas écrit avoué
celui qui a trait à la vidéo qu'on j'ai
pas vu mais chamakh c'est pas grave oui
un jeu sordide
or j'imagine douleur des fois quand on
ment d'éducation de savoir vive on dit
des choses et pouvant atteindre 11
bon finalement cette histoire se termine
bien sauf que les cochons alors on fait
tourner à table je devrais parce que
j'ai besoin d'elle vous savez comment je
suis mort c'est un jour ça pour sa vie
ou symbole est vrai que j'ai beaucoup de
chance nous sommes rendus à 50 50 50
on pourrait leur donner un dernier tour
de bon c'est bon tout la perdre 50 pour
l'apéro d'accord on affiche la troisième
question dans quelle province au canada
et ont le plus susceptibles de consommer
de la marijuana nom du poulet est un
poulet élevé aux ormes à lomme on voit
la façon de faire
la montagne ce n'est pas la réponse est
pas aucune de ces réponses la chanson de
ferrat ferré
je vous dit ontario c'est dans cette
province on est plus susceptibles de
consommer du poulet élevé aux hormones
d'accord donc c'est le québec c'est pas
très gentil ça pour l'aider le daily
mail à mes côtés j'ai perdu 50 boules de
marie-claude un coup c'est comme ça
pas de chance a tourné raymond vous
garder vos 50 boules qui vous restait
tout perdu alors malgré mon nez il n'y a
pas de poulet aux hormones au canada et
voilà du coup les aux antibiotiques
oui mais pas pour longtemps donc c'est
une vieille rumeur c'est connu une
fausse nous appelle ça comme une fois
légendes urbaines dalton a annoncé alors
en 1973 il y avait eu on avait fait de
l'utilisation d'hormones pour l'élevage
de volailles et et on pensait que ça
allait à engraisser plus rapidement les
animaux ça n'a pas duré longtemps ça a
été vite dénoncé puis bros finalement
aujourd'hui on est encore là plusieurs
années 1913 c'est loin on croit encore
certains croient encore que là ils
voulaient sont mal élevés c'est une
question d'information
ouais voilà c'est la vraie journaliste
parmi nous y'a que les êtres humains qui
sont mal élevés morales de notre
histoire aujourd'hui voilà alors on est
prêt pour l'image la semaine vous
connaissez la pétition je réponds pas à
bout par man et vous faites valoir vos
arguments pour que ce soit la réponse la
bonne réponse quelle est l'image de la
semaine on va présenter l'image la
semaine en vidéo dans un instant ça se
passe à la méridionale
oui ça se passe en amérique du nord
est-ce que ça se passe un des braqueurs
toit des raptors de toronto
qu'est ce que c'est des raptors c'est
quoi des rapts l'équipe de basketball
on regarde la dépêche de palans pagny
bon ok on va regarder la toute première
victoire dans une fille voilà elle nous
donne la réponse
la première fois que canada remporte way
est là il est vrai sport qui est inventé
au canada malheureusement je ne gagne
pas de points mais vous 1946 alors là ça
s'est passé dans la tête de venir note
toronto toronto
non non halal et laval
vous pouvez vous nous raconter
l'histoire parce que vous la connaissez
vraiment vous avez vous êtes un fan de
basket pas du tout un fan de barques par
l'expert l'invention canadien d'origine
oui ça c'est l'origine exactement où est
un canadien est un prof d'université il
ya une minute du patrimoine si vous
allez jouer là dessus dans
l'encyclopédie canadienne qui est très
très drôle qui est très bien joué parce
qu'on les voit jouant avec ce ballon et
le professeur qui dit dribbler et riz
blé ne marche et peut-être et c'était de
placer le ballon dans un panier qui est
accroché en hauteur et à chaque fois le
concierge devait prendre son échelle
c'est tout le but pour les élèves les
pousse à bouger la concentration s'est
par la suite pris part ça tout est mis
aussi de partage aussi par c'est un
sport d'équipé
est ce que le combat skate ayant un
chronomètre qui dit vous avez 25 minutes
pour la balance et quand vous entrez
dans la zone doivent être temporaires
autant c'est tout c'est fini en france
et c'est fini on a juste le temps de
faire un dernier basket les bouffeurs
oui voilà c'est fini on en paie ni
mondiaux qui sont très forts au
basketball
croatie et voilà à la semaine prochaine
tout le monde au revoir oui bravo
[Musique]